PAUL LEWIS: So this is device
agnostic development.
And I'm Paul Lewis.
I'm the guy looking confused
over on the left.
Well, I'm actually on
the right right now.
I'm on the Chrome Developer
Relations team, and I spend
most of my days talking about
and looking at rendering
performance.
PETER BEVERLOO: I'm
Peter Beverloo.
I'm a software engineer
on the Chrome team.
I work on Chrome for Android.
And I mostly spend my
time pushing the
web platform forward.
PAUL LEWIS: So we ran
a small survey.
And we asked developers two
questions amongst many.
And the questions we asked them
were, which form factors
do you support versus
prioritize?
And as you can see, perhaps
not surprisingly, 96% of
people said, we support
desktop.
Which was pretty
much everybody.
And 2/3 of people went
for phone and tablet.
But as you can see on the
prioritization side, 81% of
the 200 or so developers that we
asked said, you know what?
Desktop is our top priority.
So just take that in.
Four out of five developers are
just going to focus pretty
much on the desktop.
Now, this leads us
to a question.
If we prioritize a single form
factor, what happens?
Well, the answer is probably
quite obvious, right?
We start to build on the
expectations of capability.
We build expecting that we're
going to have desktop-like
performance, that we can expect
to see big screens,
good GPUs, good CPUs,
a lot of memory, all
those kinds of things.
PETER BEVERLOO: So along
comes a new form
factor, such as mobile.
What does this mean?
Well, we've been creating
websites for desktop
experiences for quite
a long time now.
And desktop experiences give us
a number of advantages over
more limited platforms, such
as mobile devices.
As an example, there's this big
screen available to you,
which has a lot of space for you
to put content on, or to
put data on.
But on mobile, this
is different.
And it's not just the screen
size which is different.
It's a lot smaller.
But it's also in terms of
a number of additional
constraints, such as
computational power.
We create websites using a lot
of JavaScripts, for example,
for scrolling or
for accordions.
And while this works fine and
acceptable on a desktop
machine, on a mobile device,
will just look janky.
So along comes a new
form factor.
But what?
It's not just about desktop
and mobile.
The web actually goes quite
a bit further than that.
And this is something
we've only started
to see quite recently.
Back in the days, there used
to be mobile devices which
were capable of internet using
I modes or similar systems.
But they weren't really
internet.
You could see a webpage.
You could talk to a server.
But their experience
was quite limited.
These days, mobile devices such
as phones and tablets,
they're basically on par
with desktop devices.
And they just work, just like a
desktop machine, of course,
with a number of additional
constraints.
Now, we're going to see more
and more websites coming
through televisions or
through consoles.
On the television, the screen
is a lot bigger.
But we also know that the user
is sitting away from the
screen, quite a bit further than
is the case with mobile
device or a desktop machine.
Which means that, as developers,
we actually have
to change how we create
that website.
With console, be it a portable
one or be it a stationary one
next to your television, the
story changes completely
altogether again.
And with portable devices,
portable devices such as
consoles, they can be similar
to mobile, like a telephone.
But they could be entirely
different as well, with
different forms of inputs and
different types of managing
your data with some of it.
And we really don't know.
What is the next device?
We've got desktops, mobile,
televisions, consoles.
What device is going
to come next?
Is it going to be wearable
computers?
Could be anything.
PAUL LEWIS: So the point that
we're trying to make with all
this is that it's just
the web, OK?
We have this propensity for
talking about the mobile web.
We don't talk about the
desktop web, though.
We don't talk about the TV
web, or the console web.
We just talk about
the mobile web.
And that's fair enough,
to some degree.
But what we need to start
realizing, I think, is that
it's just the web.
It's consumed through a number
of different devices.
And a good experience matters,
no matter what the device.
So then, becoming
device agnostic.
If we figure that we're going
to have people connecting to
our sites and applications
through a bunch of different
devices, how can we
start actually
being device agnostic?
So the grand unified theory
of devices, sounds good.
We figured we can actually
turn this on its head.
We can actually start figuring
out what the
constraints are, OK?
Instead of device capability,
what about looking at the
device constraint?
And we figured there are
actually these three
constraints.
And we can assess every device
that we know about today and
the ones that we don't know
about today, the ones that are
coming tomorrow, in
the same way.
Network--
how quickly can it pull stuff
down on the wire?
What's the latency?
What's the bandwidth?
If it's network constrained,
it's going to be slow.
Compute constraint--
so how quickly can it
process information?
How much memory has it got?
Is it good at calculating my
styles, laying out my page?
What's the CPU like, OK?
And then the last one is a
giant, shiny monkey head.
Or it's about rendering.
It's about pixels.
How quickly can it push pixels
around the screen?
Does it have a good GPU?
And when we start actually
looking at it from this
perspective, what we can
actually start to realize is
if we distance ourselves from
these constraints, if we start
planning for these constraints,
then what we
realize is that we are in effect
becoming agnostic to
them so that when we hit a
device with one or more of
these constraints, then
we're not actually
as bothered by it.
So instead of relying on the
capabilities of a desktop,
we're now going to spin it on
its head, look at these
constraints in turn, figure out
what comes up, and how we
can distance ourselves
from them.
PETER BEVERLOO: So let's look at
a few of these device types
and map them against
constraints.
And this creates quite an
interesting matrix.
I apologize for those
of you in the back.
It will be extremely
hard to read.
So I'll just name what's
on the slides.
On a desktop machine, the
network will generally be
quite good.
You'll be connected to your
home DSL connection, which
will be quite performant.
Computational power will be
decent, even for older desktop
machines, while they're still
better than mobile.
Rendering performance will
be decent because they're
multipurpose machines, and
they're not just created for
streaming video.
So they'll be able to
display a website.
And the screen is big.
Maybe not as big as a television
in terms of
physical size, but often you
have a monitor of maybe 20 or
24 inches [? of text grid ?].
And as a developer, that
gives you a lot of
space to play with.
On mobile, it's a little
bit different.
With a mobile device, you
can be on the move
at any random time.
And you cannot rely on the
network connection to always
be available.
So network conditions
are quite bad.
Computational power can be OK.
There's different classes
of mobile devices--
tablets are, of course,
entirely
different from phones.
But even within a single class,
such as a phone, there
can be quite a lot
of differences.
We've got phones of
over $500, $600.
There's phones of $50.
And computational power will
rely a lot on the capabilities
of the actual device.
Rendering performance
will be bad.
We're trying to get to
60 frames per second.
But it turns out to be really
difficult to get
there on any platform.
And the screen is quite small.
That's the physical
screen size.
While the actual logical screen
size, so the number of
pixels which have to be shown
to the user can be a lot
bigger because we've got
all these awesome
high resolution fonts.
For televisions, well, they're
standing in your house.
I don't often walk around with
a television behind my arm.
PAUL LEWIS: What?
I do.
No, I don't.
PETER BEVERLOO: OK.
So the network conditions will
generally be similar to your
normal desktop computer.
Computational power is bad.
It's meant for showing video,
not for showing a website.
Rendering performance will be
bad for the same reasons
because the device has
been made really
for a single purpose.
And the screen is pretty big.
But the resolution can be
smaller, and in some cases
even smaller than
a mobile device.
Now for consoles, it's quite
similar to mobile.
It depends on the kind
of console, really.
You can be on the move
at all times.
Computational power, well,
they're meant for games, for
interactive imaging
while websites
can be static content.
Rendering performance,
again, it really
depends on the device.
And the same goes for
a screen size.
And for the new class of
devices, we just don't know.
We have no idea what's
coming to get us.
PAUL LEWIS: Well actually, to
be fair, if we just take a
step back, we actually don't
know on any of these.
Because let's say desktop,
take that for a second.
It could be a laptop, as well.
And we said good
in the network.
But what if you've tethered
your phone?
PETER BEVERLOO: Or what if you
have a dial-up internet
connection?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
At this point, actually all
bets are off, right?
Because on pretty much any
of these, you can find an
exception, OK?
PETER BEVERLOO: So the sad
reality is that everything in
this matrix is a "maybe."
We just don't know.
And the only real way to figure
out what you need to
optimize for your website is not
to just blindly apply all
the best practices you can
find around the internet.
You need to measure, and you
need to look at your
statistics.
Go to whatever statistics
you have.
Look at the devices which your
visitors are actually using.
Optimize for these devices.
Use a number of available APIs,
which we'll come back to
later in this presentation,
and actually measure where
your performance bottlenecks
are.
So one way of actually measuring
what's going on are
the Chrome DevTools.
This is built into
Google Chrome in
all the release channels.
And it makes it entirely
possible to accurately measure
any aspect of what--
at any time-- what's happening
on your page in terms of
network, computational
requirements, and
rendering as well.
We've got a series of videos
available on YouTube.
They're called "The Breakpoint."
The screenshot
here is showing Paul Iris on
the first few seconds of a
presentation which gives you a
video introduction to a number
of features available
in DevTools.
There was a talk yesterday
about a Chrome DevTools
revolution, which we'll have
shown you about a number of
new features, which have
recently become available.
And we've recently updated the
DevTools documentation, which
you can definitely check out as
well, and which contains a
lot of information about how
to measure exactly what's
going on on your pages.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, so we've
established that we could be
on any device.
And we can't really predict
exactly what the constraints
are going to be for
that device.
So now, let's step into the
network computer rendering.
And this is actually essentially
a performance talk
by the back door.
If you've been up to the third
floor and seen in the Chrome
area, we actually have
a performance area.
And network, compute,
and render are in
fact those three areas.
If you've not been, you
should stop by.
But what we're going to do is
we're going to step through
the common issues that we see on
each of these three areas,
and I'm going to try and find
ways of distancing ourselves
from those constraints.
So irrespective of which device
we're actually hitting,
if we hit that constraint,
we've done everything we
possibly can to try to make
that a non-issue.
PETER BEVERLOO: So the first
thing to keep in mind is the
page load time.
This basically describes the
time it takes for the user to
start an [? execution ?] action,
like clicking on a
link or entering a link in a
browser address bar until the
time that they see the
page and that they're
actually able to use it.
Now, you've got all
your visitors.
If your page on a mobile device
takes more than three
seconds to load, then 57% of
your visitors will go away.
They'll just leave.
They'll go elsewhere.
They might search for
an alternative.
They may know an alternative.
And they're gone for
the day, basically.
Now, it gets worse.
From all these visitors, if
your page takes more than
three seconds to load,
46% will not return.
They'll find a competitor
of yours.
They'll find an alternative
source of the data which
you're giving to them.
And they'll start preferring
that other website just
because it loads a little
bit faster.
And probably the worst statistic
is that 22% of your
visitors will tell
their friends to
not use your website.
Now, let that sink in
for a little bit.
That means that over one in five
visitors of your mobile
website will tell their friends
to not visit your site
if your page takes more than
three seconds to load.
That's quite a lot of impacts.
And one thing to keep in mind
here is that the perceived
loading time of a webpage is
actually 15% higher than the
actual loading time.
And it gets worse because when
they're talking to their
friends about this, they will
remember a loading time which
is up to 35% slower of
what it actually was.
So while it actually could have
been three seconds, in
their memory, it may very well
be up to five seconds or more.
So there's a few things
we can do.
And probably the biggest
contributor to having a big
load time for your webpages
is having a huge number of
requests on your page.
Now, for every request through
your page, we can look at the
costs implied by it.
And we can split it up into
three different ones.
Firstly, there's the
latency costs.
For each of these requests for
the resources, which could be
an image or a style sheet, we
need to make a connection to
the server--
or well, in some cases.
Because in either case, we might
be able to reuse the
connection.
We need to request a resource,
get a reply.
And that could take a little bit
of time, especially if the
resource is hosted on a
different server, in which
case a DNS lookup might
be necessary.
Now, for big resources such as
images, bandwidth might be a
constraint.
If I'm on a 3G connection and
I'm sitting on a train, then
it will take a while for that
image to be available on my
mobile device.
And of course, there's
a financial costs.
This is not just about visitors
which you may lose if
your site takes quite
a long time to load.
But Paul and I are from
the United Kingdom.
And if we want to use the mobile
internet on our normal
phones here in the United
States, than the cost is up to
$8 per megabyte.
Now, you need to have a really
good server or websites if I
want to use it at that cost.
So probably the easiest thing
to do here is obsolete a
number of these requests.
For every single one of the
resources on your page, ask
yourself, do you
really need it?
Can you maybe get around
in-lining it on the page, by
concatenating stylesheets,
so if you have several
stylesheets in a single file?
Or can you perhaps minify them
to reduce bandwidth costs?
And making optimizations such
as these will often show to
have a big impact in the base
loading time performance of
your websites.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, a lot
of people already
do this one, right?
Most people, when you speak to
them, they say, yeah, we can
concatenate and minimize
our files.
The next thing that we want to
talk about is reducing the
image overhead.
A statistic that you may have
heard of, and if you haven't
and it's the first time, it's
a really good one to put in
your head, 60% of web
traffic, 60% of the
average webpage is images.
And that gives us a huge
opportunity for
optimizing our network.
Can we change formats?
In the case of WebP, by
switching to it, the Chrome
Web Store saves several
terabytes of
transfer every day.
Now, it may not be that
it's going to save
you that much transfer.
But you can immediately start
to realize that, actually,
instead of JPEGs, I should be
using PNGs, or PNGs instead of
JPEGs and GIFs maybe,
or even WebP.
It depends on the actual image
and what you're trying to
achieve and so forth.
But spend some time figuring
out whether you can change
formats, whether you
can change quality.
And that will potentially save
you an awful lot of data.
And the next thing is actually
request images that are the
size you need.
Responsive web design has
become all the rage.
And it's really quite cool.
But there is this problem with
it, which is that people often
request their full
size images.
And then, the user ends up
paying a tax, as it were.
We rely on client side resizing
to get it down.
But we end up requesting a much
larger file in some cases
than we actually need.
There are loads of things that
you can do on the server side
to actually let you scale
down and cache a smaller
version of the image.
So if you're not doing that,
take a look at that one.
And then the last thing is,
do you even need an image?
Oh, controversial.
You could get away with
SVG in some cases.
You could get away with fonts,
web fonts, with icon glyphs.
So take some time.
Just have a look at those and
just play around, see if you
can actually get rid of
some of your images.
60% of the average page
is going to be images.
So if you can get rid of that,
that saves us a ton.
PETER BEVERLOO: So one of the
solutions available to you if
you have control over your
server itself, so over the
Apache or EngineX installation,
is that you can
look into using mod_pagespeed.
mod_pagespeed is a plug-in made
by Google which basically
gives you a free pass to
a quicker website.
What it does, it looks at
your web page before
sending it to the user.
And it will look into ways
to optimize your page by
in-lining resources, by
concatenating style sheet
files together, and by doing a
number of optimization steps,
which just generally
make it faster.
Of course, this does require you
to be in control of your
web server.
But if you're not, there's
another tool available called
PageSpeed Insights.
Many of will work on the
front end of a website.
And this tool is as simple as
enter the URL of your page,
click our button, and it'll
start downloading your page
simple start analyzing it, and
it will show up with a number
of suggestions on how you can
optimize the page itself and
make it faster to load and
to display to the user.
Now of course, these two tools
will only optimize your page
to the best of their
abilities.
But they do this by looking at
the average page, what they're
doing, and applying these
rules over your site.
Now, your websites
are not average.
They're special, because
in a way there
is no average website.
And the only real way to
optimize the page itself is by
doing it yourself and by looking
at what pieces of
information or resources on your
page actually impact to
reduce performance.
Now, we've already spoken a
little bit about DevTools,
which make it possible for you
to look at exactly which parts
are taking a long time
in the loading
process of the webpage.
But another API available to
you is the resource timing
API, which exposes high fidelity
information about
most of the resources which
you've included on the page
itself and gives you insight
in how long it took to
actually look up the DNS for
that resource, to connect to
the server, or to download
the resource.
And especially if you have
clocking resources, such as
scripts, it can be a great way
to actually figure out which
script is blocking your page
from showing up quickly.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, so we talked
about the kinds of things that
you can get into for actually
transferring your size in apps
down to end users.
Now, we actually step into
the run-timey bit.
It's actually running.
And this is the bit where
we talk about compute.
So we've got everything
downloaded, or we've got
enough to get going.
And now, we want to talk about
what that actually involves to
solve for compute.
So the first thing we need to do
is define this term "jank."
Now, you've probably heard
it over the course of
the last few days.
Let's define it again,
just in case.
Chrome is synchronized to the
refresh rate of the device.
Now, at 60 Hertz, that means
you've got just about 16 and
1/2 milliseconds to get
everything done.
And that includes Chrome's
housekeeping It
includes your code.
And that's a bunch of things
like layout, recount style,
paint, composite, JavaScript,
all that stuff.
16 milliseconds.
I don't get much done in 16
milliseconds, but Chrome
really, really does.
We call this the frame budget.
And if we don't hit that frame
budget, users notice it.
It's kind of this hitching.
When they scroll and it hitches
and hiccups, that's
what we call "jank." So when
we talk about jank in the
coming slides, that's what
we're referring to.
We're talking about busting
that frame budget of most
likely 16 and 1/2
milliseconds.
So the first thing I want to
talk about in the compute area
is style recalculations.
Now, it's very common when we
do apps that we change as a
class on the body, OK?
And you do that for maybe state,
or you maybe even do it
for styling.
The problem is the size
of the tree that's
affected can be huge.
And you see on the left hand
side-- hopefully you can see-
I was changing a class
on the body.
And I was affecting just over
23,000 elements by doing that.
The calculation style effort,
then, was 20 milliseconds.
Now, this is Canary
that's telling us
the elements affected.
So if you haven't seen that
feature, it's a really useful
thing when you're trying
to figure out,
what was the impact?
There's a corresponding one
for layout, as well, which
tells you the scope and
the size of the layout
calculation.
So, we've changed the body,
23,000 elements, 20
milliseconds.
I knew that I actually
wanted to affect six.
And when I did that, it was a
fraction of a millisecond.
And it sounds obvious, but only
change the things that
you need to change.
Go and have a look
at your app.
See whether you're actually
overdoing your style
recalculations.
Layout thrashing--
if you've not seen this one
before, this is quite a
fascinating one, really.
So this little bit of JavaScript
at the top allows
us to get the thing called
target from the DOM.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to go through a
bunch of other elements, and
we're going to ask--
we're going to set their width
to match the target's width.
Pretty trivial stuff today.
What is that, three lines
of code, plus a comment?
OK.
The first thing we need to note
is that asking for offset
width is going to cause
Chrome to do a layout.
So it goes off, and it says,
all right, what's the left,
the top, the width,
the height?
What do I need to know about all
the elements in the page
to be able to give you a good
answer on offset width?
So it goes off, and
it does that.
The next thing is that first
element gets its style width
value set to the
target's width.
The problem is by doing that, we
just invalidated the layout
calculation that we've
just done.
So then, the next time around
the loop, we ask Chrome to do
a potentially very expensive
layout again.
So we do this get, set, get,
set, get, set, get, set.
And the problem is this adds up
really quickly, especially
when layout is expensive.
What we should be doing is
getting once and setting many.
And it probably make
sense when you
hear it in that sense.
The thing is to realize that
offset width is actually going
to cause the layout to happen.
And you can Google
that, how to not
trigger a layout in WebKit.
And you'll see a very good blog
post that'll tell you
which ones in WebKit and Blink
will cause a layout to happen.
So avoid layout thrashing.
Two very simple things there,
layout and style calculations.
PETER BEVERLOO: So a browser
is a very particular set of
skills, skills it has acquired
over a short but quite
eventful career.
You should not do in JavaScript
in an imperative
way what you can do in
a declarative way.
Animations and transitions are
excellent examples of that.
Five years ago, six years ago,
perhaps even more, we had all
these libraries such as
jQuery or Dojo, which
had animation libraries.
And it allowed you to animate
items on your page.
It allows you to change the left
property from 0 to 1000
and move an element horizontally
over your page
without the user having
to do anything at all.
And that's awesome.
But this is really costly
because every time the frame
does something, and often a
library internally sets a
timer to try and match the frame
budget of the browser,
it needs to look at
the position.
It needs to do a re-layout.
And all of these are really
expensive operations.
Now, there are excellent
alternatives available to this
in CSS to do it in a
declarative way.
And by doing it in a declarative
way, you're
actually telling the browser
what you want it to do instead
of telling the browser
what it has to do.
And by telling the browser your
goal, you're basically
saying, OK, I want you
to do this effect.
But please do it in the best
way you can do it for me.
And by using the CSS transitions
module or the CSS
animation module, the browser
is actually able to optimize
all this JavaScript code
away from you.
It can do these animations in
some cases on a different
[? fret ?].
And this will look a lot better,
and a lot less janky
for the user, while also taking
a lot less CPU, while
it doesn't eat away from
your frame budget.
And it works regardless
of many of the
constraints of the device.
Up until a few years ago,
fixed precision was
unreliable.
It could stick around
in the view ports.
It could be janky if
you were scrolling.
Now, lately, in pretty much all
big mobile browsers, this
has been fixed.
And of course, it works in all
desktop browsers, as well.
So if you have an element
which should always be
available in the view port of
the page itself, just use
precision:sticky.
No, precision:fixed.
And don't use JavaScript to
keep it in exactly that
position using the scrolling
position, for example.
PAUL LEWIS: But you could use
positions position:sticky.
What would you use
position:sticky for?
PETER BEVERLOO: Well,
position:sticky actually is a
new experimental feature
in Chrome.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah.
You can go to the Chrome
flags page.
You can enable it in Chrome
for Android, as well.
And position:sticky
is somewhat like a
fixed position element.
But if the parent element is
not inside of the view port
itself, so if it's scrolled
away somewhere, then it'll
just be an in flow element.
If the parent element comes in
the page, then it will make
sure that the element is--
that the sticky persist
element is visible.
But if the parent element kind
of moves out of the view port
but still is visible, then the
element will stick around in
the view port as if it
was fixed positioned.
And an example you might know
which uses this quite a lot is
an address book.
If you have a lot of names,
then the header, which
contains the first letter of the
names that are currently
being displayed may stick around
at the top of a view
port for a while until the
next letter is up.
And the fourth big point is keep
your event listener code
to a minimum.
Some event handlers, such as
scrolling events, will be
called many, many, many times
per second, sometimes even
multiple times per frame.
And any processing you do in
these handlers will eat away
from your frame budget.
And this will definitely limit
the time Chrome has to display
your web page.
And as a result, you
might miss frames.
PAUL LEWIS: One thing you can
definitely do with that one
is, say you're doing something
in your scroll handler, just
get it to store the
last known value.
And then, schedule a
RequestAnimationFrame.
Because what will happen is
most of the time, you have
like four or five of
these running, OK?
You get like four or
five in frame.
But you actually only care
about the last one.
So you just store the value.
And then, send a
RequestAnimationFrame frame to
actually deal with the
last known value.
This is called debouncing
in some places.
Debouncing is the most
common name for it.
You just basically, rather than
running that expensive
code in you scroll handler,
just keep the value.
And run one handler
at the end.
OK, so we've talked
about network.
We've talked about compute.
So let's now take a look at some
of the stuff that happens
inside of render.
Now, I have DevTools
open here.
And this captured something
which is quite expensive on
the paint side of things.
And if you look, we've twizzled
down one of the
[? pen ?] records.
And we spent 13 milliseconds
decoding a JPEG.
And we have 16 milliseconds to
do everything, not just paint.
And then, we spent a further 71
milliseconds dealing with
the resize.
Now, this is what I was talking
about before about
responsive web design
is that there's
potentially a second tax.
And before, we talked about
reducing image overhead.
But we talked about it from
the network constraint.
We also have a render constraint
because we actually
have to process these images.
So actually, just getting in
the smallest possible image
and in the correct dimensions
is actually extremely
advantageous.
So check out DevTools if you've
not seen that feature.
That's really useful to actually
find out your decodes
and your resizes.
Paint costs--
so whenever you scroll or you're
interacting with your
page, the things that change,
or the things that appear on
screen, they need
to get painted.
And since painting is actually
quite an expensive thing,
depending on the styles that you
apply, we have to keep it
to a minimum.
So there are two things that
are actually involved in
reducing paint costs.
The first of those is actually
reducing the size of the area
that got painted.
So you see I've got
showPaintRectangles switched on here.
So you go into DevTools,
hit the cog, switch on
showPaintRectangles, and then
interact with your page.
Now, as I roll over these
elements, you can see that
they're flashing red, which
is Chrome saying,
I've repainted those.
But watch there.
When I scroll, the whole
page flashed red.
Now, that should be a warning
to you that the entire page
needed painting.
And that's potentially
an expensive thing.
And it's the kind of thing
that gives you those big,
green bars.
OK, now there's a very specific
reason for this one.
But I'll let you figure
out what that is.
The thing to know is
that you're looking
for those small rows.
The question you should be
asking yourself is, am I
seeing the bits getting
repainted that I thought were
going to get repainted?
Is it predictable to me, as in,
I rolled over this, and I
expected it to repaint,
yes, it did.
When I scrolled, I didn't
expect to see the
whole thing flash red.
The whole screen flashed red.
So there's something
to look at there.
The second thing was we've
reduced the size of the
painted area, is to then reduce
the complexity of the
painted areas.
So we've got another tool
that's fantastic.
It's called Continuous
Page Repainted.
And what it does is it puts
Chrome into a mode where it
forces Chrome to repaint the
whole page every frame.
You see, it switched on there.
It puts this little chart in the
top right-hand corner with
them the number of milliseconds
that it took to
paint the page.
Now, what we can do is we start
switching off styles.
And in this particular case,
switching off box shadow or
border radius is the one that's
actually dropping that
time to paint really far down.
Now, I'd much rather you
didn't walk out of here
saying, box shadow is bad.
Border radius is bad.
We shan't use these.
That's not what we
want you to do.
What we want you to realize
is that your styles have a
corresponding cost.
And there is a tool in DevTools
that will let you
figure what the cost is.
And you can use that to your
advantage to move away from
that constraint so that you're
not render bound.
OK, so reduce the paint size,
then reduce the complexity of
your paints.
PETER BEVERLOO: So far, we've
talked about technical
constraints which apply
to you as a developer.
But eventually, what we really
want is to give the right user
experience to the end user, to
the person who's actually
using your page.
Now, one thing to realize
is that the user
comes for your content.
They come to your website
with a specific purpose.
That could be to get
information.
That could be to use
your service.
And they don't really care about
the big image header
which you had to have at all
of the top of your pages,
which basically just means that
they have to scroll the
page before they even
get to the content.
You, as the developer, have
all these constraints.
But the user shouldn't
have them.
And the main thing here, the
main takeaway, is that if I,
as a user, use my mobile device,
if I use a phone to
look at your website, I really
don't care about how well it
works on a desktop machines
because I use a mobile device.
And the other way around,
the same goes.
And while you probably want
to offer a different user
experience, because after all,
they're different classes of
devices, you should offer
the same functionality.
And what this basically means
is that the content on your
page or the services, it's fine
to refactored them or to
reshape them in a way that's
more optimized for the device,
as long as you don't offer
reduced functionality such as
a simple entry page.
Sorry, you can't use
the [? fee ?]
[? guide ?] at this time because
it's not optimized for
mobiles, PCs, and desktop.
That just scares away users.
When you develop a website for a
desktop computer, you've got
all this real estate
available to you.
You can put content next
to each other.
You can put it on top of each
other in any format you want.
Especially for text, you can
have a news article.
You can have a bold
introduction.
You can have related information
about the company
or the people who
were mentioned
in the article itself.
And this is nice because on a
desktop, because there's all
this space, even relatively
big amounts of
text look quite moderate.
And it doesn't fill
up your screen.
Now, for mobile devices,
this is a problem.
Or actually, for devices with
constrained screen size, this
is a problem.
Because if I look at exactly the
same text, or maybe even
one paragraph of text on my
mobile phone, then my entire
screen is filled with text.
And that's quite intimidating.
If I then start to scroll down,
and I get five or six
more paragraphs, then I have to
scroll for several seconds
before the text stops, even at
relatively high scroll speeds.
And this is intimidating.
And this could easily
scare away users.
Now, we know that you're
not always in
control of your content.
So changing the text itself or
changing the images might not
always be a feasible solution.
But you can at least pass on
the message that the users
care a lot more about getting
an optimized experience and
care about getting the same
functionality than they get
for getting all of the text
and all of the side
information.
PAUL LEWIS: And one thing to
notice here, just if you go
back, is that at the bottom of
that, we've got an image
that's kind of suggesting
something like responsive.
Just bear in mind, if you do
do this kind of responsive
thing, just watch out for that
tax that I talked about
earlier about resizing
images down.
Make sure you always request the
images at the right size.
OK.
So we have a couple of
suggestions, as you've just
seen, because we think it'll be
good to give you a couple
of suggestions for
your workflow.
The first one is, assign
somebody that you used to like
to your team as the sheriff.
They'll probably become
unpopular pretty quickly.
However, they perform a very
important role for you.
As you can see, the idea is
to clarify and set some
constraints before you start.
How much time are we going to
spend in garbage collection,
paint, composite, layout,
recalc style?
Where are we going to spend our
time, on the assumption
that we've got a network
constrained device, or a
render concerned device?
Where are we going to actually
spend that time?
Then, that person is
going to track it.
And they're going to stop
you from shipping if
you don't hit it.
Now, the question then becomes,
well, what numbers
should we have?
And the honest answer is, it
depends on your application.
But have that person--
a lot of times, when we speak to
developers, performance and
this kind of stuff is often
a bit like a unit test.
Are we fast?
No.
Whoops.
What we're talking about is
building it in from the start
so that it's something that
you're continually checking
all the way through.
And there's somebody who's
owning and is responsible for
you as a team.
Check out jankfree.org.
That's a bunch of slides.
It's a bunch of articles.
It's a bunch of videos, all of
which are designed to help you
with these things we've talked
about, and in a lot more
detail than we've been
able to cover.
So that's a fantastic resource
that you can track.
So, should we conclude?
We should, because it says
"conclusion" on the screen.
PETER BEVERLOO: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Super.
PETER BEVERLOO: It's not about
the device which users are
able to access your website.
It's about the content and
experience which you're
delivering to them.
And while the content and the
functionality should be the
same, you can optimize them to
create a user experience
specific to the different
devices.
PAUL LEWIS: The devices you're
going to deal with, they're
going to probably have
at least one
constraint at some point.
Even on a desktop,
you might have
multiple processes running.
There's no guarantee that
you're going to be good.
So you figure out ways to
actually just reduce the load.
Fight against those
constraints.
And you will be agnostic.
And mostly, let the browser do
what it's good at doing.
If you're doing stuff with
JavaScript, and you don't need
to do it, don't do it!
Let the browser do it for you.
PETER BEVERLOO: And just to
reiterate on that content a
little bit more, users come
to your page for content.
I've said it a number
of times.
And I just say it again.
And re-factor your content in a
more direct and concise way
to get it to them in the
fastest way possible.
Because after all, that's
why they're there.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL LEWIS: We have a tiny
amount of time for one or two
questions, maybe.
So if you have a question,
go up to the mic.
And we'll see if we can get
through any of them.
And then, if you want to find
us after, we're going to be
upstairs in the Chrome
area, probably
in there for questions.
I'll be in the performance area
if you're interested.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
The last couple I/Os we've seen
a lot about getting rid
of jank and using the debouncing
technique that you
guys have talked
about to do so.
Which strikes me as a bug in the
spec because I don't know
why anyone would ever care about
getting 200 touch or
scroll events per frame.
And yet, every single
application that any developer
here is going to write means
that we have to take all this
data, persist it somewhere,
use it in yet another
function, and let it be garbage
collected later.
Is that something that we should
address at a lower
level than the JavaScript
that we write?
PAUL LEWIS: Well, I think
if that's how you feel,
definitely involve yourself in
the spec process for sure.
It's something that we're
trying to watch.
And I'm interested in it
because, especially as I said,
I see a lot of code going to
scroll handlers and touch
handlers that doesn't
need to be that.
So there's a certain amount
of, should this be spec?
Should this be developer
required?
I haven't got a good use case
for multiple scroll handler or
multiple calls of a scroll
handler, for example, inside a
single frame.
But I wouldn't like to presume
that nobody does.
But I'm not saying that
they do, either.
So I guess it could
be something
that should be specced.
And I'd involve yourself in the
spec process, and see if
we can hash it out.
PETER BEVERLOO: Well, a lot
of specifications--
and really, keep this in
mind-- by offering
asynchronous functionality
rather than synchronous ones.
And even though this is often
not the case for event
handlers, yet for getting many
kinds of data, it will allow
it to do it on the background
[? fret ?], not block any
other processing, and
just come back when
everything is available.
OK, we've gone a little
bit over time.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, so I'm afraid
if you've got got any
questions, just come and
find us upstairs.
Thank you.
PETER BEVERLOO: Thank you.